- So, das war's.
Ich kann nicht mehr lernen.
- Was du bis jetzt nicht weißt,
wirst du in den nächsten zwei Stunden
auch nicht mehr hinbekommen.
Ruh dich lieber noch ein bisschen aus.
- Da hast du recht.
- Überraschung!
- Was ist das?
- Das hier ist die Wahlbenachrichtigung
für die Landtagswahl im nächsten Monat.
- Ich kann mich nie entscheiden,
liberal, sozial …
- Na ja, also Hauptsache nicht konservativ!
- Das kann man so auch nicht sagen …
- Wen oder was wählt man in Deutschland?
- Es … ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Also im nächsten Monat
wählen wir den Landtag
für das Bundesland, in dem wir wohnen.
Dann gibt's noch Kommunalwahl,
Bundestagswahl und Europawahl.
- Sebastian versteht es scheinbar
auch nicht so ganz.
- Also, ich verstehe es gut genug,
um keinen Quatsch zu wählen.
- Wir leben in einer Demokratie.
Viele Meinungen sind erlaubt.
- Und wählt man eine Person
oder eine Partei?
- Also, es ist so:
Mit der Erststimme wählt man den
Kandidaten des jeweiligen Wahlkreises.
Mit der Zweitstimme die Partei.
Wenn eine Partei oder beziehungsweise
wenn von einer Partei
mehre Kandidaten gewählt wurden,
als sie Sitze hat,
dann gibt es Überhangmandate.
Aber so genau versteh' ich das auch nicht.
- Aha …